[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Welcome back
to the "Next" live show.
As promised, fellow developer
advocate Kelsey Hightower
is here to join us.
Thanks for being here, Kelsey.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
I'm happy to be here.
STEPHANIE WONG: So earlier
we heard TK's keynote.
What are you most excited about?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Well, given
my background in Kubernetes,
I'm most excited
about Anthos, which
is kind of giving
Kubernetes to more
people and their environment,
so they can run it on-prem,
you can run it on Google Cloud.
Also I like the
addition of Istio,
so giving people the ability to
manage their networking playing
like they do for their compute.
And I think the
other thing I'm most
happy about is more
managed databases,
so now having SQL server.
Lots of our customers
ask for SQL server,
so pairing managed databases
with something like Kubernetes
is kind of a perfect match.
STEPHANIE WONG: Right.
And Google has a
really strong tradition
of developer teams passing on
creative software innovations
to our emerging
developer audiences.
What tools can you tell
us about that are also
empowering our enterprise
developers with years
of experience and
proprietary systems?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah, I
think for the biggest thing
is meeting developers where
they are, so kind of integrating
with their IDEs, giving
them familiar open source
technologies.
So a of developers
are running things
like Docker and Kubernetes
on their laptop--
Envoy packaged in Istio.
So what we're doing is taking
all of these open source
projects that you may be
using on your own machines,
maybe even internally,
and we're just
adding a lot of
that support stuff
that you would need to run it
in production in the enterprise.
RETO MEIER: So we can see
that values are shifting up
the stack with higher
level sets of services
and new abstractions.
How is automation evolving
the developer experience?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Previously, we've
been trying to automate a
lot of bad practices, right?
If you automate directly on the
virtual machine, for example,
now you're starting to
automate around scripts,
we had a lot of configuration
management tools,
but the APIs weren't there.
Now, as you move up the
stack, things like Kubernetes
give us a declarative interface
for deploying on a distributed
system--
so containers, batch
drops, con jobs.
So now we start to
think about automation.
You're finally targeting APIs.
So what we were able to do
for traditional software
development, we're now able
to do for infrastructure.
So bringing things like
Istio, which gives you
a declarative API
for the networking,
things like our service add
on give you a declarative API
for your serverless stack.
So when you look
across the spectrum
now for infrastructure, you're
now programming, finally,
towards well-defined APIs.
STEPHANIE WONG: So this is
sort of supporting people
where they are.
And I want to talk about GKE
on-prem and hybrid workloads.
What are some of
the benefits of it,
and what can sys admins
kind of reap from that?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah, I
think since Kubernetes came out
everyone was like,
I want it, right?
And GKE, when you
click that button,
you just get this
magical cluster--
production ready, ready to go.
And the next thing
is, well, what
about my existing environment?
And many people have
kind of tried to do it
and not everyone has the same
level of expertise or time.
So the nice thing about
this is that we're
going to take GKE, the same bits
that we used to host on GCP,
we're now bringing that
into your data center.
So we've given people clear
guidance on the lower level
requirements, and then we
just layered GKE on top,
and then we do the same
APIs, the same control plans.
So if you're using things
like Terraform on GCP,
you're now able to
point that same stack
in your on-prem environment--
get that same workflow
that you love so much on GKE.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
Now, Kubernetes is being
adopted and adapted
to meet more and
more technical needs.
Tell us about how GKE hub helps
admins with hybrid environments
do their jobs better.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Yeah, so GKE hub--
so once you kind of get
a taste of Kubernetes,
the next thing is you want
Kubernetes everywhere, right?
Every problem you see, you want
to rub Kubernetes on top of it.
So a lot of our customers
have more than one cluster.
If you think about it,
a lot of our customers
value high availability,
they'll have a cluster
per region or per zone.
So once you start to have
a collection of clusters,
even you bring in
on-prem into the mix,
you need a place to aggregate
all of those things.
So a GKE hub represents
is the ability
to aggregate all of your
Kubernetes clusters, even
the ones on-prem, and
then once you have that,
you have a centralized
place to do things
like policy management.
So once you have a
Kubernetes cluster,
the thing you have
to think about
is security across
all those clusters.
And one thing that's kind
of hard or error prone
is you have to try
to figure out how
to get your configuration
correct across all
of those clusters.
So the hub is going to
be the anchor point where
we build a lot of those
additional tools that
allow you to manage everything
from a central place.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
Well, thanks, Kelsey.
We really appreciate
you taking the time.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Awesome, thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]